what's up everybody my little jingle now
good morning everyone Persia here
Ritchie's joining me welcome to GameSpot
live we are chilling and yes indeed
happy Monday another cool thing to
introduce you guys is our little morning
you know coffee and chat water but it's
a coffee
you got the we're good we're good
but yeah you guys honestly there's
always so much happening in the world of
games today and all that good stuff and
you know every morning we come and we
play and we have a great time but we
also like to chat with you guys and so
we're gonna start using the first five
minutes of every show to chat talk about
new things happening or maybe some cool
updates going on before we hop into game
play of course today we are gonna be
celebrating the 15th anniversary put
some apps in chat if you feel that old
and everybody in the chat but yes
January 11th was actually the official
15th birthday of Resident Evil 4 so you
know that was like over the weekend 2005
yeah we we were out during the weekend
but we have to celebrate it now we have
to we can't miss this and if you guys
like this idea of playing like
anniversary video games let us know in
the chat because that's all you know any
reason to play old games we love is a
good reason enough for us you know any
any reason at all exactly chat so for a
quick little morning show we're talking
about some upcoming 2020 exclusives that
are coming to the PlayStation this year
oh yeah and there's a lot of really good
ones we're not gonna go over all of them
cuz obviously we got like 40 minutes off
already yeah and we have a video but yes
you can check out our video that's gonna
be on the channel later today that's
gonna be a more extensive list cuz
there's a lot of things and this is just
PlayStation we're talking about this
year alright
I think it's a cool concept and actually
like the movies so that predator hunting
ground oh yeah that's coming out where
you can
their play as a predator or please
Dupree I think that one sounds really
cool and I'm I'm pretty much looking
forward to the passing I have yeah I
can't think of well you know I'm just
mentally already comparing it to that
really old game for like no you hold
there it was like for like the atari
jaguar where you can play as like a
marina predator or an alien and that
like it was it was kind of on a crappy
system but like like i wanted it to be
good the heart was there but yeah let's
do it right let's 2020 fresh start it
but that's exciting
i love those movies to all of them what
about you what are you looking forward
to you know i there's a few good reasons
like well let me just start over
i I've wanted to get into persona and
yakuza and both of them are having like
either a new sequel or some sort of
compilation this year and it might be a
good way for me to get into it like
finally both of those series because
persona 5 oh what's the call I wanted to
say golden but it's like the definitive
version of persona 5 everyone here in
the office loved yeah Roy oh that's what
it is and it sold like contagious around
here and you know I get total FOMO
because I haven't played a single one I
never got into the series but it looks
fun and this might be my year to do it
like I might go big and do persona 5
royal but you guys know me you know if
there's a prequel like alright that's
always my problem I want to play 1
through 4 for this but to really love
and appreciate 5 the way it should have
been intended but I might just jump into
that same with you Cuza although there
there's gonna be a full I believe a
physical collection for 0 through 5
somebody else games everyone in the
office loves those games too so same
deal like I get FOMO and they look fun
and it's kind of a back in the day I was
always originally seen as some sort of
spiritual successor to Shenmue which is
also likely but they're both made by
saying there's a lot of similarities but
I do want to get into those this year so
I'm looking forward to those there are a
lot of new games but that's me I'm
always going you know
backwards with my log of games to play I
think as most of us are just because
there's so many games nowadays I'm also
gonna throw a quick you know low-key
shout-out to that Iron Man VR game
because one I just love me some VR it
looks super cool I wanna be iron man who
doesn't sick like you put on the helmet
and you are Tony Stark you know yes all
of those and you know we're curious to
see what you guys are looking forward to
obviously this is just our a little
quick morning jump start like the
espresso shot so I guess you could our
little chat you know let us know what
you guys think if you guys also please
chime in I mean it what games are you
looking forward to this year some pieces
some PlayStation exclusive and yeah we
talked about PlayStation exclusives
today but throughout the week we're
gonna be highlighting some of the other
exclusives we already have a switch
exclusives video up right now and
available to watch if you want to check
that out but we may touch on that later
on this week but shout outs to David
yeah our very own David making that
video and of course more PlayStation
exclusives to come in our own video
later today so don't miss that
alright ten seconds left
I'm actually really excited to implement
this aspect to our live streams just
because we already like to talk a lot so
yeah sometimes it's nice to just get
that out of the way now and and then get
to the gameplay so thank you guys for
tuning in and chatting with us here but
I think it's time to get to some
Resident Evil 4 let's see
right before I begin though Jason and
the chat says Zombies Ate My Neighbors
remake and yeah Mon I'm on board for
that
oh that would be sick okay so we are
playing John Luke's PC version he has an
ops team so we're just gonna start here
it's controller compatible love that
gonna start a brand new game and we'll
check the volume actually
we were just talking about how there was
no menu music on that hello the game
there's a lot of good music in this game
and none of it is in the beginning that
I forget it it was the year when those
grisly murders occurred in the Arklay
mountains yeah soon after the news was
out to the whole world revealing that it
was the default of a secret viral
experiment I think we all know the story
of risky before so I'm comfortable
skipping this know if you can skip this
oh let's try the virus broke out in a
nearby mountain community you're right
[Music]
my prisoner on button nah they just said
no probation well you guys are gonna get
an earful and a little reminder of the
events of Resident Evil 1 3 and a chance
for us to say what everyone in the chat
Rowland Nazir I'm just trying to see how
I what's up Connor yeah everybody you
gay we see you thank you and happy
Monday and you guys just Rock
yeah look at that we got a lot of people
ready to play resonable for me too I
love the Resident Evil 2 it's still one
of my favorite games and I didn't play I
played three like you know a few times
but when four was announced I was just
tripping out because Leon is back to the
station and I didn't have a Gamecube so
I had to wait til the ps2 version came
out was to assume responsibility sons
like vacation music even though it's
about to be the worst day of his life
the second worst day of his life feels
like yesterday when I was when Persia
was playing the switch version yeah that
was spoil it by modern-day shooters this
was game-changing though this was this
was the first like a third person like
over the shoulder type of resi
together these cheesy lines I feel bad
for talking over them but they're gold
that's like the same voice actor for
that guy in like every villain in
Catalan you geez I forget where he is
but that dude speaks Spanish and you can
hear them later on as the enemy
oh I can't wait for that bingo line so
bad so good it was right before how many
times have we finish this game in our
lives Persia I don't mean I never
actually know information about it I've
only ever played this game in pieces
with people shine ever all the way
through by myself I found the button my
bad okay let me just you know there we
go just getting your poor evil five was
actually the first wasn't evil I really
like Doven tune really really liked just
testing out my buttons yeah cuz it's not
like a current day use of the analog
sticks like oh here we go
anybody home yeah yeah but yeah
15 years ago holy [ __ ] this dudes about
to fight me
these Plagas they're not sir
they kind of live their lives like no
but they're grossly infected and it's
kind of weird to see this guy just
cooking his beans by the fire yep I even
feel yeah I put his gun away cuz he felt
safe because this seems normal he's like
what kind of turn was that no there's
Ashley Bucky he basically said whatever
you doing here and get out cabron oh
great
we're not welcome here so sleek yeah
time to time to refresh my shooting
skills like that tumble yeah there's
that dodge roll man you can do it out a
two-story window wrong button
[Laughter]
okay now I can like kick him I think you
know thank goodness he's so patient I'm
not gonna kick him I'm gonna press pause
with them there it is I have to get my
bearings back oh there goes my ride
they're like after this guy
honestly oh that's not my ride that's
the smart thing to do
so intense I kick one guy in the face
and the whole town's after me we got
Jason in the chat already saying what
are you buying we have a better merchant
yet but you know what's up enclosure
says best Ari game all caps okay oh it's
so weird like the the right analog stick
doesn't move it sort of moves your
carrot or your camera but not your
character yeah it's just been a while
y'all it won't budge he's got to do a
dodge roll out the window it's like he
knows despite the power of observation
who didn't touch the door or anything no
yeah oh yes it's time even Resident Evil
officially tweeted then they're like
rolling it to Monday like very rusty man
okay let's try that again
there's a quick turn yes oh absolutely
there is Jason campus I'm noticing you
you I'm noticing you I gotta make some
changes to the controller this guy needs
to go that's exactly what happened yeah
come on strike Leon he's dead break him
look I'm reading the yellow guys this
stinks so rusty we always take the green
yeah you know what eat it right now wait
should I wait to combine I do but that
gives me like if I'm in the red I want
you want to try to switch your control
yeah there were
I think that's the wrong there we go
inbreeding I think that was the issue
there was another xbox360 controller set
up there was option sorry I'll just get
my bearings back
oh I goofed it up here the dog okay
that's the aiming is fine I got to save
the dogs no time to talk oh yeah they
give you goodies cuz they're bad birds
but I hate shooting birds I'm not doing
that anymore
you remember what happens when you save
them he helps you in a boss fight later
I do remember setting him free once good
boy and then I was laying how you just
jump out late yeah okay yeah chat saying
so many memories with this game
absolutely right in fact like I'm still
getting used to it's actually been a
while there we go first up Persia also
let me know incognito
no no one right except this farmer with
a rake no I keep reloading instead of
firing I was trying to go for the kick
but I ended up killing him by him oh
well he was bad okay maybe I'll I'm
running low on ammo and everything very
rough start
he says Leon is still a badass as always
of course it's that haircut man right
he's so angsty
yes I need that absolutely sudeer saying
this is my face again welcome yeah
you're in the right place Bob Joe Bob
Jones in the chat he says hey all house
fill-in
happy Monday Bob Jones okay I'm gonna
get my ass that cancels a lot of okay I
keep that one hella far away that one's
dead yeah now I'm gonna take care of
this guy yeah you don't want to kill
them all but I'm getting my practice in
cuz I already got chopped up yeah we get
the you know the oil the the joints yep
I'm rusty yeah yeah I'm gonna ignore
those guys even though they're gonna
throw a boulder at me later
no well as what console we're playing on
they are actually playing on PC right
now yeah you know wish we could have a
classic setup to go really old-school
yeah yeah John Luke thank you this is
his copy on Steam sly Han says why are
the controls so bad other than freaking
cute I'm really I guess you know I never
played the actual GameCube version I'm
trying to reload not shoot the one time
I'm trying to she's laughing - see see
see see I'm trying to uh in battle I was
reloading like a dork imagine IRL how
you holding up pretty badly actually the
control scheme is not as good as I
remember yet just TBH here yes yes thank
you
Huntington I'm getting a little better
though that was a good warm-up oh I can
look ahead Ben said I wouldn't even be
mad if they added Ari for Leon to smash
yeah does his roundhouse kicks that'd be
great
the voice at peak aniyo that translates
to I'm gonna chop you up into babes
dude that was my ride in I'm gonna reach
into his pocket and like grab the keys
and get the hell out of here psych that
Lea just she just swearing up a storm
like a sailor I don't want to face the
town need help I need any bullets I need
all right well I think I have to start
facing them Bob Jones said the Wii U was
the best version of this game because I
had all the extra stuff and could be
used with the Wii gun that actually does
sound super fun yo oh I kicked that
lady's head off that was a combo
straight-up dude I creakin says game
spots real cool and you know what what I
see that your room yeah you're real cool
I love having you here
pink hub with the aah my childhood yes
15 years ago
crazy right utilizing this kick to save
bullets by God that poor cow is like
what the f is going on here look she's
walking towards a menacingly yeah
eventually this whole knife combo
doesn't work so well because there the
plug has come right out
I'm screwed yeah four bullets
I got to do that cool kickin move I'm
getting night straight up
we heard it's time for it's time for his
brave jeez I didn't think I'd be so
rusty at this telling you the control
everyone get cakes that is like an AoE
just like everybody that's alright need
a reload he called me an imbecile
dang Reaper said I ranted this game from
blockbuster that's how old it is
probably one of the last games you ran
in from blockbuster me too Hey Oh scuse
me Oh get away just calling me an idiot
Oh behind me the flank excuse me ma'am
there you go they're like get up we need
to get the shot II says Ben oh yeah I'm
past due it's in one of these houses I
think so let's throw something at me
[Music]
no no car there we go instability
animation on kicking the door down it's
vital you have to it's like oh gosh okay
I just wanted to reload and I forgot
what got no bullets in fact I think the
bells about to ring soon I have to do
something to trigger the bell oh that
guy was on the roof throwing I was
looking for help I think you know what
nope I'm already not calming I'm not
just playing the game
okay that's block that dude said I'm a
copy to bed oh and okay
about to break it all these gonna be
broken do I have time yes money oh my
god yes
there we go no I was like we need some
help yeah
Oh Saved by the Bell
oh my god Blake now he said we have to
go
I like this translation yeah happy to
help
[Music]
welcome to the street welcome man also
thank you for the translation Richie
no problema bingo it al Bano very good I
mean go ahead I said it right but you
got it I understood you I'm actually
using that duolingo app to God dang sure
like brushing up on my Spanish combine
these two or I think I'm gonna look
around first it's safe at the moment
thank goodness I'm gonna look around we
need some hail I need health and maybe a
third plan to get a full heal okay I was
here but there was a check got a tummy
ache classic way to show pain and
there's evil just like hold your side
even though look I'm fine
that cow okay thank goodness I can't pet
the cow - points Capcom hey yeah
you mixed that with the green and red
herb you get a full heal and if you
unfortunately if you harm the chickens
Gordon Ramsay yeah even though jeez I
swear in the original like Resident Evil
1 & 2 instead of a vile like that it's a
little rolling paper you told they
totally it totally look like you can
smoke it so bad I don't even know that
growing up I forget someone pointed it
out I was way too young to get the
reference but like what what do you mean
you're wiling oh there's something on
the roof pink hub with
the assistants head to the watchtower
for first aides braid ooh bless you I'm
just checking out the town first damn
time this is why when I play games on
Tremont I always wanted to break every
single box me - is that not that's not
the move is everyone like go go go
because I can go go go but I will die
die die
way more yeah I mean I don't mind I like
you know the completionist aspect like
whenever I play Kingdom Hearts I spin at
least like 35% of the time breaking
absolutely everything I'm so bad when it
comes to that like I cannot play that on
stream because I'm the same way I would
take forever and waste everyone's time
nico says nostalgia yeah he goes where
were you in 2005 when this was released
or tell me the first time you played
this might not have been 2005 2005 no
2005 was the year I won my first local
Halo 2 tournament oh that's cool
that's really memorable halo 2 man all
right moving on
never mind I need the key okay
excuse me mr. chicken there's a way out
over here that's where I'm just gonna go
someone said shoot the Bell shoot the
Bell do something thank you for that I
[Music]
was up there that's why all right let me
see if I can I'll just go back up nice
animation you don't have to do anything
paradox says wait what happens when you
attack the chickens and re4 they're not
finish that sentence you get an egg and
eggs are good for your health a little
bit of the Bell it's not like Zelda
where you will regret it oh yeah they
just died but they give you an egg
sometimes and sometimes it go a golden
egg which I believe refills your help
all the way I don't want to kill these
chickens to live their best lives you
know I'm gonna skip the bell for now
because I'm clearly missing it
move on free y'all lapis go blue says
this is my first Resident Evil game nice
wow you know what that's common the
older I get the more I hear that I'm
like I'm so old
mine was - I was alive and around for
part 1 but I played - first oh there's
these little things
my face was actually five that's good
very action II replays like witnessed
old school ones until later on my god
see like that would be my same reaction
I'm like no this too hard the aim of the
things we don't really get close but I
forget what they do there's a bunch of
these scattered know it's probably for
an achievement oh my god we have alarmed
the residents of evil sorry I'm tripping
me up even though there was a hell of a
bell that rang that got it it's
somewhere else I guess
alright I'm saving oh excuse me sir I
want to do videos for like you know
getting beat up in games whoa whoa so do
you see the foot view there's a another
wolf you need help
he's just messing with the chickens you
don't even he hungry hungry oh look at
that
an egg did I shoot a chicken he's had an
egg in his pocket right okay gusting
gross gross man I remember the first
time you know that we all know the
chainsaw guy and he cuts your head off
if you get anywhere close to him and the
first time I was playing this it was
like at night we have a separate room in
our house and I was like yo like that's
the first time I my head's been like cut
off so severely in a video game you know
it would call my girlfriend was like
babe I got my head cut off in this game
I'm like no option to like walk through
you can just jump over enough where are
you getting these from okay I don't
think I went the exact right way yet or
I'm jumping ahead but let's see rushing
it down let's find out together y'all
it's been so long
oh and I got a run for my life
sprayed sweating I was like what's X on
the Xbox controller I don't look down on
so many different oh you know I was so
athletic and I just blew it you know
that's the nicest way to die in this
game actually that's one of the cooler
are that's one of the most chill ways to
die in this whole game goodness
whoa
all right now I know at the end to use
well it might change it up sometimes
it's sometimes it's the back bumpers and
sometimes it
different combination hurry up yeah I'll
get that dodge roll and then the sick
pose afterwards do you want to give it a
shot Oh we're making great time right
now
excellent Jules you can sell for money
no experience maybe I shouldn't be
wasting my bullets now we want those
spindles yeah they make for good money
later on alright nice artwork oh man
when they run away it's spider what the
I was like how did I trip the wire cuz
they're throwing dynamite at me good
lord I might not make it y'all quit hey
oh my god running slower I'm running
slow do I have any more I need this now
are you okay no I'm just trying to get
them to know we're gonna raise it bar
okay that last time I was just trying to
look for him
my goodness for the record this game's
not hard I just kind of stink that's the
rector that's the record let the record
show I'm not gonna mess with these
jewels that was pretty funny it's like
could this get any worse I was like in a
bear trap getting dynamite thrown at me
god I'm gonna take that guy out and now
where did he go now
where is he he was not where he was I'm
gonna kill that guy into the trap like
he wanted to combo your ass okay
California dreamin epic fail yeah this
has been pretty rough now I would
consider that epic fail laughing at
everything that can go wrong is going
wrong
you're absolutely right I think you're a
tilted on that second go so let's just
mm-hmm
you know we're on streams we live with
some green needs of our own
I like the way you think I'm playing too
soft on this guy who's the flarin I see
him
[Music]
I'm too far for this oh cool all right
I'm gonna go finish him off you better
not get back up there's enough no I'm
gonna have more bullets oh that's some
sweet revenge right there the gun
and a blew everyone's heads off
great-nieces let me play he's he bets
I'm better that is absolutely false
the last time I tried play this game oh
you were very very very difficult you
know what though I'm not gonna Lena I'm
not afraid to admit I'm spoiled by
modern-day shooters and that's why I'm a
straight-up ass cheeks at old school
shooting games like this you know with
time and adjustment getting used to it
all right yeah you started to get used
to it but you know in a 90 ministry in
Russia it's not long enough for me all
right
I'm sick of that guy now I think I need
some more accuracy with my little just
need and bro oh yeah I got needs to jump
we are he thinks he's cool cuz he could
throw some needs at us you can't walk
away
not special man yeah you know what hand
grenade I'm gonna go all out because
that guy's pissing me off this is just
revenge sweet don't hit the okay maybe I
shouldn't have laughed so hard but that
was satisfied exactly that was just
Redemption it was oh oh he dropped his
looking out for bear traps that's good
yeah
and spiders I think know if they're good
for anything oh no they can bite you and
poisoning you so I'm just gonna reload
my gun incorrectly okay because I want
this box okay how can I use my head okay
great I like how they really didn't put
like that much stuff in that room but
they guarded it yeah a bunch of things
this is the trick all right
simple classic gaming move right there
just shoot the hakka
California dreamin said I think a speed
run would be easily under five hours I
beat this game like a hundred times not
me
the same music Amala supports every cow
in the name of revenge thank you that's
all we wanted to do little sweet revenge
there is there any way to do this
without my gun maybe if I throw it your
hand it'll hit both I think I have to
waste the bullet
oh I remember what's going on I remember
what's about to happen
surprise oh rich within it Leon has some
like steady issues here which is a
little more it's got ice in his veins
here we go I do enjoy me some dead space
as well oh my god me too the world
record is just under an hour and a half
sorry if you all wanted to see that Hugh
this is not a plug I like them no you
okay I have only one very important
question you got a smoke Leon does not
smoke although with all the stress he's
been through in his life start the big
cheese what
don't know what I mean by that what are
you on that was pretty tight though I
respect like the confidence behind not a
word you just ran up to him and I think
I missed a lot because I went an
alternate route but whatever
I skipped probably something I should
have but I saved our ass yeah this is
why you never skipped all right he's
dead yeah we cool where'd he go the
jacket is off I'm ready to fight now I'm
in you see like my holster and
everything ultimate costume hey there is
spam the chat with dubs cuz that guy is
the real hero in this game ooh ooh a
good sign yes
I just saved I'm not gonna save oh yeah
you have the option to open the door but
I like to keep the door
yeah I gotta assert dominance
got something that might interest you
this guy's a living legend maybe not
living but you know selection good yeah
yeah yeah okay let's see what he has
whoa whoa whoa harsh in the chat said
yeah are you for a remake with a
better-looking Leone first of all don't
be disrespecting my boy Larry okay you
want to go full auto or like Leon's got
that that haircut though you know I
think for the time that this game came
out he was very on point what's funny is
it was that was his original haircut
when like Resident Evil 2 all right what
are you I have enough money to tune up
my handgun I think I will I always try
to tune up this first some fight no I
don't money for [ __ ] I'm gonna back out
of here Ben says this arena coming up is
great so many dudes to take out yeah
definitely make sure you have everything
you need you only got four bullets oh
there's more it's weird they don't tell
you your reserve look at that yeah okay
I want to do a car actually
oh no I think I'm maxed out you can
update that later oh really
I had like ten bullets last let's see
yeah I just did it wrong stupid all
right then I think I know the part
you're talking about there's people and
differently you can kill this guy but it
don't do that you can just knife and he
goes oh yeah Ben I know what part you're
talking about it's about to get crazy
this area behind that wall yeah I should
have bought the rifle I'm such a dork
I was actually wondering like I remember
this was coming up soon so yeah I
remember feeling really hard and running
out of all of my ammo almost immediately
when I played this part
got to work on that like shoot and kick
mechanic I'm so glad Lee stopping point
for a little bit
I wish you guys roundhouse kick them off
the village save time
nope nope nope nope
oh here we go with that ago throwing
bombs on this wooden bridge what is
wrong with you guys this strongest
wooden bridge oh I think oh I thought I
did kick them off the music is humping
y'all
there's a million bad guys here nope
nice there we go
saving bullets you can like shoot them
off but not kick them oh no oh boy oh
then you cleaning up for me Oh what am I
thinking shotgun
oh right goodbye blow up already Daniel
says good luck surviving here so far so
good
don't you know what if you knock them
off like that you get less goodies oh
yeah true it's fine we just we're just
try to survive let's try out our new gun
yeah they call it like a TMP although I
forget what it's modeled after something
like an Uzi you still alive Oh someone
someone from afar is throwing stuff oh
my God he's killing his own people here
what what any help I think I've like red
earth oh good first of all second of all
if I mix these two I get a full heal
okay
maybe I should have saved a but oh well
oh dude okay oh okay nope
there's stuff in there though I'm gonna
pick this up there's a lot going on
yeah
I need some motivation to chat y'all
dodge I gotta kill that dynamite guy oh
this is fun jump down okay I have to
find out who's growing that just
probably up here yep
you are oh nice noise dances you got
this you really do you're killin Airy
thank you no I want to kick this down
can't you do that y'all stupid there's
probably someone behind me what am i
doing great I'll see you at the fire
popcorn
Oh someone got up I heard wait yes I
want all this
yo pockets someone's still
forty-something me okay might as well do
this one here Thomas Oliver says we
believe in you
flex emoji nice desert
all right car home says come on in you
can do this I can't this is only a jump
down point I got to figure out what that
guy is I'm just gonna take him out he's
selfish Oh grandpa's low I channeled my
energy Swift enough with these guys
yeah a what back for more eh you think
it set off watch Oh sometime you can the
music is still going I don't like when
you go watch shows at Universal and
stuff and they always have that guy of
talk to like it's done double to fall
[Laughter]
he's taking too long but yeah save a
bullet use your knife
it's got dead already I'm pretty sure
that's a song he took like a 30-foot
ball you got music is over yeah that did
sound like a song song I think it's like
save a horse ride a cowboy save a bullet
use your knife yes some of that yep
yellow herb oh goodness
I keep it's so weird
LT is aim down sights like for normally
but it's your it's your knife in this
game oh it's a little trippy alright
gotta find the pieces to unlock that
big-ass door let's go get some bullets
good oh you know what I didn't do I did
not utilize those red barrels their gas
barrels everywhere I could have blown
them up now we're too skillful for that
you don't need no shortcuts ooh
just hard work and dedication yeah
getting my herbs all back he's a lot of
them earlier
okay they keep treasure boxes here
straight up oh it's just the the wind
blowing that's me and cotton every time
I see movement of any kind a tree yes
it's just a teammate me too but it says
you can swap the aim buttons in the
options Oh
protip then although I'm finally getting
used to this this setup if you guys
tuned in from the beginning you saw how
rough it was I was getting my ass handed
to me but then I started roundhouse
kicking people it was great ok this
should be the second half yes now we're
set I can find combine these two or the
hell
oh he's in treasures ah yes it's
wonderful
what games you guys want to see a remake
of says Brandon all my wishes came true
when they remade Resident Evil 2 3 is on
the way but what else you know what
Syphon Filter oh yeah I love that ps1
game it's one of my favorites no one
would want to remake I don't think but
you know what if you see if you saw a
version I think you might recognize it
what about you I'm like racking my brain
well the ocarina of time you guys know
how much I love that game yeah some just
don't need to know they stand the test
of time
but I want to see a new f-zero y'all
whoa are you listening to do did they do
it I don't know what's the last f-zero
game that was out I just remember
playing there really old ones where am i
that that was not a door that I go
through I think this was just a little
bonus area I'll double-check them wrong
and now it's quiet in here thank
goodness so windy out there
all right oh yeah
oh no one behind me no I was afraid
oh that was gonna throw stuff at me
oh yeah nope
invincible for the kick animation it's
the best thing in this game pretty go oh
he he flew
thank you sir may I have another go to -
ball - bulb they teamed up on me when
did we save you know I think it like
picks up to a recent area okay hope not
save since like I where are we oh I have
the gun we're good okay mmm-hmm because
I feel like last time I played I not see
it for a while yeah we're good
that's a good idea the games encouraging
me to use this all right you know what I
want to see hmm
every week or any version of Metal Gear
one says Jack go ahead Persia I'm sorry
okay I got my attention what do you want
to see a remake of parappa the rapper oh
man I haven't thought of that game in a
long time I feel like that would be a
good new game
Parappa the rapper cuz I want to run
around like like in an open Parata
you try to duck
No all right that guy I'm sick of it
he's still alive enough oh I'm wasting
really good really good kick that guy's
a tank he is he's the one who would
who's responsible for my death that was
way too close guys are you alive don't
see let's don't be you know okay
I know they still got the tunes bumping
oh there Deary mastered parappa they do
then others enchants are confirming
there you go
which came through instantly yeah
honestly I hadn't played them since like
the classic ones and maybe like some
emulator versions just when you want to
like relive in the stalls oh you just
downloaded her fun thank you
however they were never really coming in
that 100 why why alive thank ya coughing
cat all right I think I had one of these
that I will use because it was a mess
back there
I whip you you know
[Laughter]
like we hold suspense yeah no no they're
bull alive it's okay they don't got the
strong arms they can't throw that far
can I like headshot him from here head
glitch no they made it so on purpose
where'd they go
what thank you so much there we go
enough I want to hear it
all right some air traps
too far I don't appreciate this music
right now
just trying to disarm these bear traps
guilty terrified
Bob Jones says Ritchie just wants to
play this game out one each feel at all
time I know
let's take it oh there's some guy it was
hiding by the door
sorry I don't look there there we go
I should have dropped that on your foot
God last frame of animation right there
oh that music really gets you I have
these headphones on it's so intense okay
yeah no quick say no what keep I'm too
jumpy I'm on edge guys alright okay I
see you I'm going the wrong way
alright see look I'll just open the door
but if there's a bad guy behind it you
keep the door they go flying snake says
happy birthday re for our little man is
growing into an ink see teen loves this
game yep I was 19 when this game came
out I was like we almost have the same
birthday me in this game oh it's very
special oh yeah
the anniversary was on Saturday but you
know we don't play on Saturday Monday
through Friday we had to come back to it
so this was a any excuse to play this
game exactly no no I got it
snitchin yeah he said get on my turn
and up still haven't mastered it people
are gonna come down here okay oh you got
no friends
alright person up or down it's probably
the wrong way that looks that means like
the next scene is about to happen let me
go down first or like that you're gonna
enter the next big room fish let me
knife them humanely what version of fish
farming is real and it's very sad it's a
lot like this what let me thank them
humanely there we go and I heard him
instead I should've just shot him in the
head
look at this big Dam ok I can rotate it
right yeah I can't fit this in my
inventory quit unselecting I can't keep
these plants let me read this I need a
bigger backpack Tetris there we can
select I just want to move this over oh
my god what the hell no this stupid fish
wasn't worth it can I eat him oh you
know what not worth it I don't know I
can't I can't get these things back it's
not I'm just gonna skip this you know
what I don't need I'm not poisoned so I
don't need a full heal I'm gonna get rid
of this use it okay oh my god I hate
this menu why is it so I'm trying every
damn bud
forget okay hey oh that's the button to
do it okay watch this this should work
now oh my god
rotate sit your ass down alright good
now we got a smelly fish in our backpack
[Laughter]
okay great Oh
birdies I have full inventory what do I
really need money is always good room
for this comeback so soon
no I combined a full heal there you go
there's a few ways to get a full heal I
love it put the fish in a plastic bag
when you litter they're carrying around
money for some reason though I like 200
bucks from each of you know that's their
payment all those letters they deliver a
crow mail Wow looks like it rotates I
will rotate it down nope wrong way up
and up that looked like the symbol on
the church and it's not right oh that
was right something oh the door in
question all right we got a portrait of
what the same Salazar no no no there's
no one watching this does look like the
merchant huh I'm raiding his house he's
a nice setup taking his stuff reading
his diary
taking his money like I helped me out
what am i doing robbing him for can I
jump out this window it's too quiet I
can translate something about jokes
Lambie all right getting my buttons
ready yo help me out where's that guy
familiar just remember if you become I
don't know like 30 of your homeboys was
not yeah yeah I wasn't enough you should
have killed me same blood same blood you
know I guess that's how you sound after
you get choked out by someone you know
ten feet taller than you
Persia are you sure I just want to keep
the window okay Oh cut scene coming up
go back in the room after eight oh eight
you're blowing it for us dude I'm just
kidding we all know she's in this game
all right go back into the room after
the cutscene okay no no I'm gonna get
rid of this dumb fish once in front wait
what's it do
no he's gonna it heals you does it do I
eat your silly when you're fighting
zombies right in the middle of that let
me reload my gun here or can I combine
make some room did that clear anything
yeah there you go
all right three go back playing yeah
okay yo do the optional cutscene by
going back in the air let's see
Thank You chat
oh my gun you guys wanted to see this he
was just kind of nice to us I told you
oh thank you Chad
yeah I couldn't miss this étoile the
mysterious woman in the red dress nope
[Laughter]
dude it's to ward off evil spirits yeah
it keeps us smelling good to you know
vampires only garlic zombies sound like
this why are there thousand portraits on
this guy
oh wait what do you mean you don't have
a thousand portraits of yourself around
here I kind of want to the same one
though not different well who's hungry I
do have a fish now an egg I don't have
room for a stupid yeah I think I only
picked one fly I mean they should switch
back over yeah the fish in question
we're working on I don't know to sell or
to eat but my health is too high right
now so I'm not gonna eat it there we go
loading up I don't know I'm glad I did
that
all right you don't mess around with
that guy oh come on
that guy needs to go now oh that's worth
it
nope that wasn't phone back no I'm dead
no I'm not dead but no no way
who keeps that guy needs to go it's
worth it it's worth I can fight this off
yeah oh my god I need my help
what a mess the fish is a full heal
stupid fish all right look the Savior
that is the fish see that's why we have
fish
you go away got him oh no no sir in a
while that keeps screaming back to my
memory how horrifying that Oh what kind
was it Ruby Z cool
okay let's reload everything spam double
using the chat for that Oh someone in it
with a straight-up knife like Norman B
lady zombies or actually match me know
when to run a little bit the other ones
like throw [ __ ] at me and like miss they
do point a lot huh perfect another full
heal it is a crush of Leon Sal blamin
she's badass she's been there from the
beginning
Lea and resin evil - it was his first
day as Oh Oh looks like that we dare you
roll even go about this
I can flash them all as a flashbang and
then I'll shoot them with this shot
leave me hey guys I'll kick them all I
don't care
okay blast excuse me no no I could have
knifed him but grandpa with the hat
that's exactly what they were just
posted up waiting for me
Parkin says would you think one day
efficient save your life well yeah it
gave me a full heel pro tip
this is stressful I'm stressing thank
you Peter it's all because of this I'm
prepping everywhere I go everybody out
of my house yeah too far no I got it's
like stay down bro let's go with another
flashbang hey everybody look at this Oh
tainless said you should have saved the
flashbang for the crows uh-oh oh yeah
all right we shall live with our
consequence pop kick
Oh y'all need a back called personal
space better reload jump oh that's what
I wanted to do this whole you know
there's a little crowd control there to
keep the hat off his head and kicked his
head off his shoulders I was sick now
I'm in pain
oh boy I don't like this ambient noise I
don't the sound work I guess is better
than I remember in this game she was
still like freaking out this year that's
the guy from earlier fall off the roof
right into the trough someone threw
something on me I heard it I think he's
right behind the ocean I think there was
a guy number two headshot enough I love
that kid I am but you know I like to
play on 1hb say exactly Richie Furst
that was a healthy egg those brown eggs
I think are healthier than the regular
eggs all right
this was locked earlier we've got the
key dammit oh I have the key right stud
gotta turn around in my pocket all right
writers
this is underwhelming I thought I'd be
like a the entrance to the church just
like somebody's house
yeah Marco and the chat says mercury for
life for life for life oh you too this
is good good times I just I'm glad I'm
not rusty with the control so much
anymore because that was a rough start
yeah watch next game I play or when I
play like cod later I'm gonna be all I
need a knife this guy oh here we go
sometimes I think yeah they give you
things let me take that back yeah and a
creepy ass cellar let's go
still no word from Ashley yet she were
here to try to save her being a good guy
yep another day in the life there's a
ton of these I should be seeing a
merchant soon oh I didn't upgrade any of
my weapons last time we met so I'm
loaded how much money do I have twenty
four thousand whoo-hoo
what are you selling that would be
useful right now yeah nice what are you
boy wait God moving on yeah what I went
yeah I went in a circle yeah play this
game in a while although I did buy it on
the PlayStation 4 when it was
re-released and I started it but I
didn't finish it yeah the homies
all these diamonds off the ceiling in
that room over there yeah and I'm pretty
sure I robbed your house earlier
all right let's before I spend money on
stuff let's tune up our weapons yes
shotgun needs to be tuned up I feel like
I use that a lot what do you think
should be tuned up firepower let's go
what's expensive it's okay is that old
stranger I could have expanded my
alright man put them up skidding all
right where did it come from this way no
what's it that door yeah I don't want to
go the way I came this is the way you
came thank you
what's it okay good that looks promising
these caveman alright I don't like this
I feel another rock run coming on yeah
good thing Leon is so athletic oh it's
the cemetery Church bad times this is
around the time the plug has start
coming out of their heads if you kick
their head off they're not done yet man
if I had a flash grenade you're right
they all just kind of pass out when you
do that you can pick up the money
I'm not gonna shoot them look there's a
guy over there anyway yeah
excuse me serve six slices butt cheeks I
win all right hopefully no one heard
that great too fast no no no
I thought the dynamite would blow up by
now how did I know I shot it in the air
man that's achievement worthy I totally
had that totally meant to do that
oh yeah this is re for pro league strats
right there I think this is locked yeah
I'm not even yeah she calling me goodbye
stop my bra button I'm trying to do the
quick turn yeah okay I think this area
is coming up cuz this around this corner
I remember is when they start turning
into like the advanced forms no you
first
we all took oh that was nasty the worst
way to go about it was what I just did
good thing I didn't die how did I not
die this games like you know what it's
all right
oh man I hate this puzzle all right
start with I'm gonna start with three
because that looks correct and then it's
uh one two three the symbol in my head
is not that confusing but I forget which
okay it's going going right so far okay
that circle one is not in the Insignia
so for it's this one right with the
wings on it yeah okay one two three four
I'm going with my gut
yeah I forget how this goes one two
three four again to get that other end
looking thing okay for again quit all
right so I definitely think that those
reasons
okay highlight three of them right I was
doing the whole damn thing
so I think it's these three on the right
I think so now I'm like what did that
thing look like again do we solve the
key the key lives in the same shape
right oh that's a good question no man
all right so I'll do three what the heck
and then four I'll put the spammin in
here yo max bros yeah another okay
No
quit quit operate alright let's go three
three three again no that's a circle
thing so the first ones for it go for
four
I don't know
[Laughter]
three three three four four four three
three wait what if I go three right now
it's gonna go back sander says three
three three four four four three really
all right Zander I believe Sanders I
like it
Xander has been on point this whole
state three three three four four four
oh is that you can turn them off that
way yeah four
man thanks and they're gonna save me so
much time I love you you meant yeah
Oh bless you now that jewel does that
open up the storm something like that
right that is now known as the Zander
jewel renaming it officially right here
right now or if you even pull that up on
Google to save her ass appreciate it
the jewel doesn't unlock this door on
its own story of my life yeah some I
tried to double check I'll put it in the
lock when there yeah we're not ready for
this yet or can you mix it with the Ruby
let's try it
oh no the rubies are just for sale all
right there well chill out what the game
was like freaking out on me if I use
when you kill those chainsaw guys you
get the okay if you wanted to this is
how you find I think we had our
lifelines Andy to straight in the
process we are in our last 10 minutes of
the stream we are over I'll get to go
and then I gotta find something else to
combine I'm not even gonna shoot that
target
Hirsch says you get it Oh relax I mean
fair we are running up in your house
alright maybe no don't relax see me this
whole time like stealing there oh but
this puts me back into the caves doesn't
see that's the caves though am i ready
to jump back down well only one way to
find out
unless Xander can save us again yeah
there's the homie let me just
double-check let me read what just says
examine yeah these normally go on the
you can mix jewelry together but this
one hey I can sell all those jewels to
that guy but I'm not going to we don't
have much time left
we're running low on time y'all Deadpool
says you are a good player that's really
sweet
thank you place especially for people
who might not have played the older
Resident Evil is it really is a big like
learning curve to get adjusted to the
controls it was a learning curve to go
back and dust off these controls who
maybe this door no it was locked but
there was no like yeah was there
anything else back here or anything to
the right nothing to the right nothing
past this no other information okay
chicken yeah Thank You chat thank you
all for being here everyone over here oh
and here I was ready to go backwards and
give up
just follow the people pointing in
yelling at you see ya know in the
forehead I hate that guy any projectiles
in this game Oh what snake I'm about to
get my snake got him first
[Music]
I should have used it right away we
don't have time no no time for that of
the rocks no time for the hanging extra
things down there they're here they're
everywhere
I think the troll is coming up nope I
missed the kick that was so funny I just
whipped it okay
troll time for sure right yep
I'm not gonna mow down these missing
birds hear that come on let's start the
Patrol fight
first of all hey ready how do I begin
pick up some ammo yeah like prepare
yourself yeah the troll destroys these
little houses anyway he just knocks him
over maybe I have to just leave Josh
said this makes me want to play Dark
Souls for some resources like the dark
souls of its time maybe you know I can't
imagine to be honest maybe my heart
little kids playing this and like not
dying a million times like I'm thinking
how old was I when this game came out I
was like 14 mm-hmm
so I can't imagine I would make it
through this without dying at least 728
man the troll fight didn't start I guess
I have to explore some more
yeah Charlie Charlie Charlie yeah
possible direct URL quick yeah real
quick come on it's so well-crafted like
they found the perfect Boulder to fit
exactly in this tight space how long
were they waiting well I'm not welcome
up there
what's Chad saying like do they any pro
tips on how to fight the troll I think I
just got to move on first then I come
back to that yeah get the troll when you
return not now oh did I just walk back
to backwards after we just talked about
it this is why I started introducing
like maps on UIs and games I think
probably really common people this guy
oh that was not sick wow I wanna make
every single projectile you eat that is
great that'd be you
[Music]
now just getting height for so I'm like
let's go why is it up more like warded
they are almost skinned yourself where
is he getting these problems I hate this
guy you know I really want you to
survive it but now I also want you to
take a lot of projectiles
three minutes okay
if there's a chainsaw I'll just get my
head chopped off - he's dead oh okay we
just get the whiff sounds and instead of
the [ __ ] sounds good that was
satisfying yeah we're probably not gonna
make there is I've been poisoned
how badly does it showing up
come from me that man he did not
why did he trigger a god man I'm not
gonna kill everybody we don't have much
time left the arms running for it into
speed run mode because we're wrapping up
here soon all right yeah this actually
it's probably the best place for us to
go ahead and call it we'll call it final
two minutes of the stream thank you guys
so much for tuning in chatting with us
reminiscing and celebrating Resident
Evil 4 is 15 berth 15 still hurts a
little bit still breaking but it feels
good that we can have a reason to play
the game I've got an Austin hope you had
an awesome Richie
great job totally killed it
Thank You Chad you guys helped me
through some sticky situations exactly
thank you guys for tuning in shoutouts
to Xander also helping us out today that
was awesome and of course everyone don't
forget you can catch us every weekday at
11 a.m. Pacific time right here on the
GameSpot youtube channel like we
mentioned earlier when we were
discussing some upcoming 20/20
PlayStation exclusives be on the lookout
for our feature also coming to this
channel later today love you guys so
much we're gonna sign off but have a
happy Monday see ya
you
you